we got to play an hour and a half of
cyberpunk 2077 Phantom Liberty and there
is a lot more to it than we initially
thought so let's talk about it
we got to play an hour and a half of the
game we're playing it on PC we had the
devs with us so they were able to answer
all of our questions the demo was the
first couple of missions of phantom
Liberty we got to uh save the president
whose plane crashed in Dogtown which is
the new area in the game which is
nestled in Pacifica yes uh so it is part
of the map however it is tough to get in
and out and sort of what we saw is it
was right after V had been smuggled into
Dogtown yes exactly and then we did like
whole mission where we found like an
apartment like a safe house to like hide
her away had like her confrontation and
then she asked us to go find Solomon
Reed which is Idris elba's character the
king when you first meet Idris Elba or
Solomon Reed he is a Sleeper Cell in
Dogtown he's basically been in cover for
what 11 years I think they said
something like that and you basically
need to get him out of it and he has a
very Gruff foreboding presence as you'd
expect Idris Elba to have there's a good
quest line where he asks if you've been
followed and you're like no no I haven't
been followed and uh turns out you
totally were followed yeah but the
reason so we didn't get to play this
Mission but the reason we were followed
is because we didn't do enough prep work
before meeting Solomon Reed they were
saying exactly had we done that mission
before and like kind of found the clues
that we'd be followed we could have
changed the outcome there was so much
potential for variation based on what
they were described obviously like we
didn't get a chance to see how those
changes played out but they said like
depending on what you say when you first
get confronted by Solomon he might end
up actually really pissed and like leave
and not want to help you and I was like
well what happens yeah what happened
without him good example of that too I
would say is uh so you saved the
president in the first mission you take
her to a safe house we kind of they had
to skip around a little bit so we were
missing some of the context but when the
president asked you to find Solomon read
The Sleeper Cell she asked you to take
an oath because you're a unofficial
official uh secret agent for the new
United States yes and you can take the
oath or you don't have to and if we
decided not to take the oath and Johnny
who returns obviously Johnny silverhand
Keanu Reeves was like Gabby like like
Stick it to the Man like don't help like
like stay away uh from all that but
apparently you can also take the oath
and Johnny's pissed at you for taking
the oath um but but I think Johnny to be
honest was one of my favorite parts of
what we saw of the story because it's
kind of it seems like it's diving into
another side of his character that we
didn't see which is the part of him that
served in the military and was a
deserter I really like Johnny in the
base game I thought he brought a lot of
Gravitas and energy to the story but I
feel like they were aspects of him that
weren't super well explored and almost
kind of uh like different sides of his
personality that kind of butted heads
and I'm curious to see what they explore
especially if they're heading down this
uh sort of like ex-military deserter
Direction and it really makes it feel
like integrated into the main game
because he is so involved it doesn't
feel like it's a side tangent I mean the
whole motivation for saving the
president is Songbird the person who
like contacts you on the radio puts out
the SOS
she promises like I can get rid of the
chip in your head so it like almost
reads as like an alternate path to like
progress the main story potentially
we're not really sure how it'll play out
they didn't really answer our question
about that we were like so does this tie
into the main story and they said well
it's there are things like The Witcher
um it's similar to how uh hearts of
stone in The Witcher 3 how you'd get the
the mark on geralt's face and people in
the story would comment on it yeah but
it didn't necessarily tie directly into
it but the way they're setting this up
it seems like it might tie more into the
main story and it got us thinking like
could this potentially lead to a
different ending something like that
which again they were kg about mostly
because they just don't want to spoil it
which I think is totally fair but I I
get the feeling that it will affect the
ending to some degree which I think is
really cool one thing that I was really
impressed by with Johnny and this kind
of leans into a whole other thing was I
immediately noticed that his character
model looked way better than the biggest
game they like redid it and then that
gets into a whole thing that they were
talking to us about which is they have
actually touched like the whole game and
have made a ton of changes which I was
not expecting Pavel sasco who is with us
uh Quest director at CD Proctor added
for cyberpunk was saying that there's
not a system that they didn't either
tweak update or just redo entirely and
it's it's impressive and I think it's
going to breathe life into the entire
experience totally yeah I mean just like
a small example they gave was how they
wanted to reimagine the way um like
Health Works in combat I mean if you
remember cyberpunk space combat it gets
pretty hard at the point and where I
remember just like every five seconds I
just feel like shooting up just because
like you're just constantly getting hit
and so they they wanted to change like
the way damage works so that you're not
needing to do that as much and they said
so because of that they make
um actual like Health rare to find yeah
it's actually a cool down and it's a lot
more effective it's a lot more effective
and that also then uh leans into like
other stuff like they've completely
changed the weight armor works now it's
no longer tied to clothing clothing it's
now like tied to your cybernetics and
they've completely reworked the way
cybernetics work as well yeah which
really excited is probably one of the
most interesting things that they've
changed because this time I mean it was
hard to get a full understanding of how
it worked because we were only just kind
of like guided through the menus got to
Peak it but uh it's similar in that you
can install a bunch of cybernetics but
you can't just go crazy right from the
start install a bunch of cybernetics all
over your body you have actually limit
you you have a limit that you can
increase as you I think level up and get
more cyber genetics and as you progress
you'll be able to get uh get more and
eventually uh once you hit the threshold
you will start to get debuffs for having
all of these which is sort of supposed
to simulate cyberpsychosis
um which is cool because that is a big
part of the cyberpunk universe and that
was
kind of absent in terms of your
character yeah in the vanilla game I
don't think it's going to get as crazy
as like no but we saw in Edge Runners
for example sure but it's neat that like
there will be actual drawbacks to just
yes cyber cybering yourself up they want
to give a weight to the cybernetics in a
way they kind of lacked in the base game
and then there's like so much more that
they talked about uh there's the skill
tree completely reworked the way skills
work yeah they said they wanted to get
away from skills being like percentage
based where it just like you know you
are getting stronger but it doesn't like
stat Buffs it doesn't feel like you're
getting stronger so now they said they
wanted to go more in like a perk based
Direction where it actually feels like
you add a thing and you can feel the
substantial like there's I have a new
ability now so curious to see how
they'll actually feel but I mean based
on both that and the cybernetics like I
feel like that's gonna completely change
the way that game flows I was excited to
play Phantom Liberty story wise I I had
my issues with cyberpunk 2077 story but
overall I enjoyed those characters I
enjoyed that world and I and I liked a
lot of the narrative threads in that
game
um so I was excited to see what they do
with Phantom Liberty totally
um but I think honestly what I am most
excited about is revisiting the original
game with all of these changes and
updates and just seeing how that changes
not the story Stories the same but just
how it changes like how I interact with
that world how I uh get stronger how I
level up my cybernetics How I build my
character and I I think that's going to
draw a lot of people totally to it I
mean there's like I feel like there's
just more stuff I keep remembering that
they added like they've completely
reworked the whole police system now
that was a big that is an important one
to talk about I feel like we should talk
about that yeah because people like
complained about it because it was it's
not great it wasn't very good so they've
reworked the way it works now so I think
they said like level one they'll
basically just like check the area
around yeah so wherever like if you ran
someone over and they get alerted
they'll come to that area check it out
if you're gone probably won't find you
but if you're still there and you keep
causing trouble two stars three stars
and then it builds up to yeah so at
level five they straight up call Max
tack on you yeah um and they said we
unfortunately we didn't get there
because we we were mainlining the story
and we died and I was like but they say
that you actually have a boss fight yeah
you have to do against them which I
think is really cool yeah like that
seems like a fun challenge that like I
want to pop in with my like endgame
character and just like see if I can
like survive and take out yeah like that
would be cool it was kind of nuts how
much they've added to this game like I
think we knew going in you know they're
gonna have a good story they're gonna
have future Zelda in it and and I was
feeling confident that that stuff would
probably be pretty good what really
impressed me was their willingness to
take this as an opportunity to also just
like go back in and almost rewrite the
DNA yes rewriting the DNA is a great way
to describe it so uh yeah I mean that's
our Impressions on cyberpunk 2077. uh
Jake you also have written thing up as
well a written thing yep which goes into
more depth a little more specific
um so if you want to check that out you
should do it yeah and uh for all things
Summer Games Fest stay here at GameStop